it's considered like backfire effect or
the boomerang effect we're in a
particular context if the context is a
battle or a tug of war or you know
you're leaning back and if someone pulls
on their side of the rope you don't you
don't you don't like oh cool let's go
over there you're like no no my side of
the rope harder and that's just the game
right that's the game you were playing
in that context it's you know it comes
from fight or flight it comes from our
survival instinct like hey if I'm losing
that doesn't mean I surrender that means
I fight harder and you know
psychologically doesn't make sense
you know if you just look at it from
like oh you know why am I not hearing
the information and updating my mental
model about reality and instead choosing
the fight back because oftentimes your
survival is at stake at least
historically you know
you ready go meaning love like well what
if I'm not ready maybe we should have an
argument about it yeah a week we can
indeed and we go into today ladies and
gentlemen welcome back I'm joined by
Buster Benson Buster welcome the show
thank you so glad to be here as you
might have heard we've been practicing
our arguments ready for you to tune in
today but we are talking about the art
of productive disagreement today yes we
talk about something else maybe I argue
with you and we talk about something
else and open for whatever you got no I
love having a good disagreement part of
the read you know the most interesting
part of research for this book was
basically approaching disagreements in
all parts of my lives and you know I can
tell you the bet has led to you know all
kinds of just like weird side effects of
its own so I like going down those
rabbit holes and seeing where they end
up but yeah so if you have any like
pressing like why is this thing so hard
to talk about in public we can talk
about that but yeah the I'm happy also
does like give a quick summary of the
book to if that's helpful
amazing yeah I think I've got I've had
some difficult discussions recently with
people not difficult as in we were odds
but more why is it difficult for us to
have this discussion when it's not in as
much of a collaborative environment so
your new book why were yelling why did
you write it and what's it about
yes okay so I wrote it because I really
needed to read this book I think there's
a lot of people that go out and you know
write the book that you know they about
what they know my career has been in
product development and engineering and
entrepreneurship and you know I was an
Amazon and Twitter and slack and how it
couple of my own startups rent a bar for
a while I just all kinds of random
things and so I have a pretty personal
relationship to arguing a disagreement
that I'm you know I think everybody has
on the runway but it has been my job for
a long time to facilitate sort of Dai
group diverse groups of people that have
different incentives different goals
different skill levels and helping them
all come together and get something done
so that's sort of you know I've been
interested in it for a long time in a
professional sense
and you know I think part of what it
came out of that was an acknowledgement
that were biased we have blind spots we
don't see everything the up in times
fight for being right instead of
fighting for you know the truth and we
don't really have you know as I in an
argument when our heart rate starts to
spike and our blood pressure starts to
you know go up our capacity to reason
goes down our interest in collaboration
goes down all these things basically
it's like here's the time when you need
all these skills and we're gonna just
remove them all from you very
conveniently and turn you back into like
the fighter flight you know animal that
you you were billions of years ago or
whatever so my my goal in writing this
book was to take all of the knowledge in
the world from all the experts because
there are so many books about this about
negotiation about persuasion about
rationality about using and you know
there's just like there's a lot of stuff
out there and it's all very good it's
all right some of its really dense and
some of some of its really useful but
it's really hard to understand how that
applies to our regular lives and how do
we use that at the dinner table how do
we use that in a one-on-one how do we
use that when we're fighting with our
spouse or you know a partner how do we
use that one we're you know just
frustrated and angry and we have retired
and you know when everything seems to be
falling apart all these things that like
seem to compromise us and and so I just
decided to take a deep dive immerse
myself and all that stuff and try to
synthesize it because that's what I love
to do I like to synthesize things and
make it practical so that was the hope I
think that that's one of the most
interesting things that we can do
especially as we get older and we can
draw from multiple different bodies of
knowledge different subject areas and
intellectual hero of mine novel raava
Khan talks about the fact that he thinks
joining these things is one of the
greatest pleasures that there is in life
and I have to say then the same is true
for me
interestingly I spoke to Professor Paul
bloom from the University and Yale
the other day and he recently wrote a
book called against empathy the case
rationale compassion it sounds like
you're pushing towards rationality here
how unbiased can we make ourselves how
appropriate can we make our responses
not necessarily so I wouldn't I'm not
pro rationality or against it I think
that they are their disciplines the
rationality is a discipline empathy is a
discipline persuasion is a discipline we
need to find the thing that's actually
the most practical for us to use and I
think that any of these disciplines when
taken to an extreme and applied you know
they are very useful in a very
constrained sort of sphere of sort of
debate right like if you want to be
apply science to all of your arguments
you can do that but you need a
laboratory you need research grants if
you want to apply empathy to all of your
disagreements you really need to be
super healthy and emotionally like sort
of thriving in a way that you could
actually spend all this stuff if you
want to use rationality you need to be
talking to someone that also you know
wants to play by that rule right you
can't take rationality to a basketball
court and play you know play play
basketball you have to take it to
rationalist and
and then your sparring but so I'm not
before against them I think there's a
time and a place and a context for all
these things but there is also this huge
context of our everyday lives that you
know where these things don't
necessarily work I understand so we're
talking about disagreement and the art
of productive disagreement specifically
at some point did you did you define
what you consider to be an argument or a
disagreement yes yes so I have a you
know an official definition which is a
disagreement is basically a difference
between two perspectives that you find
unacceptable
so it could be I think a is better than
B you think B is better than a if we're
both cool with that then no disagreement
that's one of us thinks hey I don't
think it's it's okay for you to think
that a is better than B because b is
definitely better than a then we have
disagreement so it's really the
unacceptable part it's like what is it
that that's what sparks us into the you
know the need to prove someone right or
they need to actually converse with them
about this it comes from a good place I
think sometimes it's that we want we
think you person a would benefit from my
view person B if you had my view your
world would be better and my world would
be better therefore I should get you to
do it
yeah yeah there's there's a selfish
aspect to it and there's a selfless
aspect to it you know this is how we
learn about the world right we have to
go out and talk to people that know
things we don't know and we have to take
their knowledge and Link it up to what
we do know and that's inevitably going
cause differences of perspective that's
what we want we want to go talk to
people that know things we don't know
the process of integrating differences
is a skill that we have not been taught
very well we haven't been taught wasted
we tend more to the anxiety we feel
about like okay well I thought this
beaver is better than a thing in my head
I'm not ready to change that yet that
makes me uncomfortable how can I match
their version of things into my head in
a way that I can keep that which often
times requires you to say well eh this
person thinks a is better than me but
they're wrong and so I'm gonna put that
that's how my don't like link it up I'm
gonna pretend like there are some people
out there that are wrong and then
there's me and now it's coherent versus
try and actually decide like which one
is the best or or is there a possibility
that they're both you know it's okay for
you to think that and me to think this
and that's totally fine I understand so
do you have a framework that people can
follow that they can look at where do we
start with the book yes yes yes so this
book is framed around eight things to
try and meant to be things that you know
are each in their own a big practice a
big way to then pulls together lots of
experts a lot of research and my own
personal experiences and all that into
something that's like hey try this and
those eight things are I mean you know
we don't have to cover them all but they
are their thing the first one is
watching how anxiety sparks in your head
so like when you enjoyed this Agreement
try to notice what sparks that anxiety
so that you can work backwards and think
okay well what was threatened what was
my value or my Dennett II or my feeling
or what felt threatened and then you can
use that to ask that person that did you
mean to threaten this or did you swear
you saying that for some other reason
because most disagreements are
oftentimes mistaken threats and they're
not actually trying to threaten you
they're actually
just ranting about something or there's
you know trying to say something but
they're saying it in a very sloppy way
so that's one and I have like tips
around how to do that with like
disagreement journaling and sort of
private journaling the kind of thing
number two is to talk to your internal
voices so a lot of us think with our you
know with voices our head we we find
ourselves sometimes like when we're when
our blood pressure is up we get angry
and we tell people to shut up and we
just try to stop the argument and when
we're with friends or we're at work
we're trying to be more professional we
use like logic we're like okay well
what's the evidence for this and how
would you prove that and let's see what
happens and and there's another one that
when those two things don't work was
like oh I just I'm gonna opt out i
motive what this conversation because
there's no point in me talking to you
you're not gonna listen to my reason I
don't want to be overbearing and or
you're being overbearing to me I'm just
gonna escape I'm gonna avoid everything
then I call that the voice of avoidance
which is the one that tends to have
creeped into our lives the most turns
out like there's so much in our lives
where we just decide you know to avoid
the problem for some reason or another
sometimes it's because you don't keep
the peace sometimes it's because it's
you think it's useless and that's where
the frustration comes in was like you
know we would want to be effective here
and we're choosing not to that sort of
annoys us and so really giving names to
these voices and starting to think about
which ones talk up and when and when are
they most applicable is one of those
chapters chapter three is to develop
honest bias so really thinking about
cognitive bias and how you can both see
it in yourself and learn to see it see
see how it creates problems around you
and how to address the problems without
having to necessarily diagnose everyone
is biased because that's sort of what
tends to happen is I could be pointed we
go around trying to set your bias for
this reason and your bias for this
reason I mean while the things are just
getting worse and worse I I advocate for
just like focus on the effects of bias
and try to fix the damage that's being
caused because that's something that's
tangible it's you know it's right in
front of you it's also the thing that's
hurting the people and then over time
you can
sort of work backwards into you know
what caused us how do we prevent it from
happening in the first place but so
those are three that we start the book
with and then there's five more but I
won't go into them because I've been
talking a long time I'm absolutely
loving it I'm sure that the listeners
will be as well I think you'd be once
we've had a little chat about those I
think we definitely go through the
remaining chapters because I don't want
to I don't want to leave that open loop
one of the one of the interesting things
you said there I certainly know that for
myself as someone who likes to think
about things in a more of a cerebral way
and you can sometimes break down a
disagreement very cerebral II you know
just go back through Thinking Fast and
Slow and start just picking up Daniel
Kahneman quotes and studies throwing
them at someone going like no
self-serving bias argument from
Authority like you just you know me and
it's like well I got a second like
you've totally bypass the actual purpose
of using biases and working out where
logical fallacies come from which is to
use them to progress the argument
forward not to break the fourth wall of
the argument and turn it into this weird
sort of dick-measuring competition about
who knows the most biases right right
right yeah that's that's the danger I
would try to avoid and you know full
disclosure like that's how that's where
I started to you know as a p.m. at
Twitter we were always we were obsessed
with the list of biases and we would
always try to like pick them out in
other people's arguments and really game
what's a 1 p.m. what product manager
okay so I was briefly what does that
mean sorry so you know the team's the it
was at Twitter at the time you have
engineers you have designers you have a
marketer the product manager sort of
works with them all and that comes up
the strategy tries to identify which
things are launch blockers which things
that are bugs that need to be fixed
first whether or not the quality is high
enough you also have to wrangle with
like the execs and other teams to figure
out you know how to get your resources
how do you prioritize your projects that
kind of thing so it's half of its like
you know managing your team and sort of
figuring out like how do we all work
together effectively and half of it is
sort of managing your relationship to
the rest of the company that must be a
very good breeding ground
to develop negotiating skills finding
middle ground compromise ensuring that
different stakeholders satisfied etc.etc
yeah yeah yeah it's definitely that's
where I realized I was I had particular
skills in there and also like I had a
long way to go early hung and not
everyone likes that role so it was
something that I was really drawn to
it's like this is a meaty challenge I'm
never gonna like master this to the
extent that I get bored right so how
much was it a similar role that slack as
well its Lackey as well yep and I had
that at Amazon and most recently at
patreon so it's a role that is pretty
common here in the Bay Area and it but
it's also ambiguous you go to every
single company that's slightly different
it's always a function of the culture
and how that company works that's a very
interesting sample of some huge quickly
growing companies fee to have developed
these skills in yeah definitely a
crucible of like excitement and torture
and fire exactly yeah I was at Amazon in
98 and it was just like the books and
music tabs were up and saying the video
tab is gonna come up soon and the
actions was gonna come up and that was
right out of college I remember being
like wow this is so I feel like I'm in
the middle of some like weird weird wild
hurricane that's like happening yeah but
yeah I feel really lucky with being in
the right place at the right time and a
lot of in a lot of ways so really say it
really sounds like you have been so you
know the listeners will know but you
won't I'm a club promoter so my job
involves me mediating between the venue
owner which were not our staff there's
about 500 of them that work for us 14 of
them of the managers and then there's
teams below them the customers the
police the council licensing orthorion
mark can learn you know and we we cross
all all different sectors of the
business so me my business partner will
do accounting will do projections will
do the marketing will do the copy will
do the HR will do the hiring and firing
will do literally everything so you know
juggling juggling these these particular
skills
is something that I enjoy I like I like
the challenge you know given your track
record of companies that you've been at
as well I think that you must have that
- yeah so we very similar we've had the
the first the first three there was one
I think it was number two that you
mentioned about where you're talking to
your internal voices checking yourself
on your internal voices and so there's
an echo
howl a quote from the power of now where
he talks about conceding the conceding
that your point is wrong in an argument
is tantamount to the egos destruction
and I often think about that when I'm
having a discussion with someone and the
listeners at home will know this as well
you have any discussion with someone and
you think right
this is irrefutable proof that what
you're saying is wrong and they don't
change their mind no no hang on a second
like I've just at least I've given you
it it's there rather not they dig their
heels in further and they double down on
that matter is that the sort of thing
that you discovered in that absolutely
absolutely that's you know it's
considered like backfire effect or the
boomerang effect where you know we don't
in a particular context if the context
is a battle or a tug-of-war or you know
you're leaning back you know and if
someone pulls on their side of the rope
you don't you don't be you don't like oh
cool let's go over there you're like no
no the Rope harder and that's just the
game right that's the game you're
playing in that context it's you know it
comes from fight or flight it comes from
our survival instinct like hey if I'm
losing that doesn't mean I surrender
that means I fight harder and you know
psychologically it doesn't make sense
and if you just look at it from like oh
you know why am I not hearing the
information and updating my mental model
about reality and instead choosing the
fight back because oftentimes your
survival is at stake at least
historically you know feels like you
know anyone has been in a really heated
argument knows that that feeling when it
and really get going in you almost
you're no longer listening it's a game
of tennis it's a verbal game of tennis
you wait for that person to finish
speaking or sometimes you don't and you
just
single-minded you got the blinkers on
like a horse in the race
and you just going for it yeah yep yep
and we're all yeah it's it's like really
hardwired in our brains we were really
we've benefited a lot from right over
time because there's so many arguments
that can't be resolved with reason you
know if something is like hey you know I
wanted to have my house right here on
this hill and you want it to but I'm
bigger I have worse I have you know I
have more swords and soldiers on my side
so I gotta have my house here or you
know like I want these goats these are
my goats you know you don't you don't
resort to property rights you don't take
it in the court of law you just settle
it right there and so this is how we
settle most of things like if you look
at a two-year-old and that has their
favorite toy they don't you know reason
about why they should keep the toy they
just yank it and start screaming
these are they work in a pre verbal
sense even even a precognitive sense
they work so they're they're deeply down
there but you know what what gets us
into that battle mode is interesting
because we don't have to operate in that
battle mode all the time we don't I mean
most of the time we were in that mode
we're not actually fighting for our
survival we're fighting for something
stupid
or something very abstract and even if
we're wrong we're not gonna die we're
not going to be kicked out we're not
gonna you know starve in the cold you
know so we should look at that that's
why it's start with like where does
anxiety spark and sort of listen to the
internal voices because that's the point
where there's this crossroads if you
back am I gonna go down I'm not gonna
turn on my battle mode
or am I going to turn on my friend mode
or am I gonna turn on some other mode
and you don't have to go into that mode
so it's a there's a choice at the
beginning I'm gonna guess that turning
on or not the anxiety mode forms the
foundation for the other elements and
the chapters is that kind of right yeah
I think I try to spend time helping
build the instincts and the practices to
have a way the mode altogether because
most of the time you don't need it if
you're if your health or your safety is
in danger
yes resort to the voice of power and
like I just yank it and try to hold on
to it whatever it is but most of the
time we're arguing each other right now
we're not we don't need to do that we've
actually benefit from learning something
new we'd actually benefit from building
a relationship we'd actually benefit
from enjoying the conversation and
building new connections so all these
other things that we could get out of a
conversation can be productive it can
make it productive in a way that's way
more rich the way more enjoyable way
more fulfilling than who's right so
there's a there's a bunch of that around
like what are the other fruits of
disagreement that we can focus on that
it turns out are like way more
interesting and fun yeah the
conversation I had with Professor Paul
bloom from the University of Yale we've
finished talking about why we think that
the podcasting platform is so enjoyed
and seeing such growth at the moment and
it's a cliche to say it's the fastest
growing platform on where our my twitch
TV whatever just because of air pods or
because Joe Rogan is a boss or whatever
whatever but I think one of the main
things is that it's it's one of the few
places where you can have two plus two
equal in five with regards to a
conversation you know I don't want the
best podcast is some bad podcasters do
this but I don't want to come into this
conversation with you I don't have an
agenda for me to come out looking like
the cooler guy right and you know that's
not your yeah you know you think you're
pretty cool as it is living in the Bay
Area so I mean northeast of England in
Winterfell
and but what we're trying to do is we're
trying to have a conversation it's one
of the few places the last bastion of
where conversations aim to make two plus
two equal in five where it's like you
know some stuff and I might know some
stuff and then together we create and
were like oh wow both of us have come to
a new conclusion and the weird thing
about it that I think is important is
that we know that we're being held to
account by an audience that's going to
be rigorous at checking us on our
[ __ ]
because if it's just a conversation
between the two of us you might be able
to lie more or bend the truth I might be
able to I could tell you that I was like
an ex-professional football player
whatever I can't do that because I know
that someone out that's gonna go that's
that's [ __ ] you can't say that yeah
so you're actually held to this
incredibly high level of intellectual
rigor and honesty and dignity and virtue
is I you know do I suppose what what are
your thoughts on these sorts of long
conversations and stuff like that is
being a breeding ground for productive
disagreement absolutely in fact you know
even through my own experience I've been
on a few podcast now and every single
podcast host I meet is so good like
intuitively understands these points
because you're on a you know daily or
weekly you know cadence doing them right
and you so you know you know that you
know asking good questions is important
you know that you know enticing people
to sort of fill in their own arguments
for something sure that share their own
perspective and share their story is
important to the conversation and you
have the time in the context and the
circumstances to allow space if you
don't you're not looking for the sound
bites you're not looking for the zingers
necessarily so
as far as I'm concerned like yeah the
book could have just been like be a
podcast host we all just need our own
podcast and it all need to be on the
podcast because everything about it I
agree is just like it's conducive to
longer maybe this is why it they're
happening right now when we need this
kind of thing and why they're you know
growing so fast is because this is this
is the antidote to you know the the
breaking news and the headlines and the
you know the rants and all that cannot
take so that stuff so yeah is you know
it's one of those things I'm hearing
from so many different angles at the
moment the long-form conversation is
something which is lacking we need to
allow people time to void think out loud
and voice their thoughts with nuance and
subtlety and error without jumping on
them and saying it's this and saying
it's that and you know I mean we asked
Paul bloom essentially why is it on
moral to be racist the other day but
that's a very difficult question to ask
someone without them going right looking
at you like you're a Holocaust denier or
something else like no no no like I
really I'm fascinated but what is the
evolution time do you know I mean
gives you time to go through it and he
questions himself and the audience get
taken on that journey so yeah you know
everyone that's this thing I've said it
a million times I think that is a good
tool to use to sit down with someone
that you know well for about half an
hour once a week put your phones outside
of the room and just talk about anything
talk about some of you seen the news
don't have anything else on just have a
conversation because for me I get so
fired up knowing that I get to speak to
someone like yourself or Aubrey Marcus
or James Clay or whoever it might be
right yeah and if you don't have that
outlet you don't realize how much you're
missing it yeah and I'm being swayed I
was originally for this book and make a
podcast and it seemed like so much work
and so hard and I know that it is a lot
of work it's very hard but I see the
benefits in in like just the the people
that are drawn to it and do the work you
know you're all very open minded
gracious you can see both sides you're
oftentimes like not polarized extremely
on one side rather you can you have a
perspective that's large enough to to
hold you know invite guests that
disagree and you know have have
conversations that are difficult like
all these things are exactly what you
know is said in the book and we we may
not all be able to be podcast host but
we are all people that have dinner with
people and we're all people that go on
walks with each other we're all people
that have conversations and write
letters and all these other things that
we can do so yeah I think it's great and
I'm definitely you know reconsidering my
my choice to not have one good good
subscriber at least you'd have one so
we've got the three chapters in what we
want to do next number four what we what
what we working on so number four is to
speak for yourself and this is sorry you
can always bring this back to the other
ones here each one sort of builds on
that on the past ones but speaking for
yourself I found especially online is an
easy guardrail to help keep
conversations on track when you start
speaking for other people or imagining
what you know how often do you say like
or do you hear people say I can't
understand why you would believe this or
why you would do that well you must be
an idiot or you must be a racist or you
must be a terrible person there was a
question there's a question like I don't
understand
something but you don't ask it right you
all you do is you take your your
uncharitable stereotype of that person
and you plant it into their head and you
say okay well you must have this
terrible projection that I have and
therefore I can judge you and understand
I think I understand you but I really
only understand my stereotype and so if
you ask people to speak only for
themselves and they are trying to talk
about something that they can't talk
about from their own perspective you're
forced to go find someone that can go
and do that for you and so find the
person that can speak for themselves
about the thing you want to understand
and so use that person to give you
information instead of your own
imagination to do that and yeah so that
leads into the next one which is sort of
paired with it which is like asking
questions that spark surprising answers
so once you have that person they're
like how do you you don't just like you
know are you a terrible person you know
speak for yourself try to convince me
that you're not a terrible person those
are terrible questions you can ask
questions that are much more open and be
like you know no how do you form this
belief do you even have this how would
you how would you articulate your
position to me
how are you misunderstood by people like
me well you know what how have your
beliefs been useful in your life who do
you look up to that has this quality and
just chart to like start trying to see
the world through their words and again
you know using the fact that they come
from a different life as a source of
information and have curiosity about it
so ask really big open questions little
bunch of questions that you've suggested
there would elicit you know hundreds of
hours of interesting conversations
between people yeah even people that you
hate yeah you know there's a lot of
people that I disagree with I think you
know I want to know in fact the people
that you agree with more likely have
similar motivations to you because
you've already selected for one thing
that's in common between the two of you
but if you don't even have that thing in
common you're like oh wow you must have
a really different world for you yeah
yeah it's really quick to see that you
know to see that if you're asking the
right question oh yeah
I know I grew up here with these
circumstances with these you know this
environment
oh wow tell me more because I don't know
anything about that okay so I'm coaching
a company out in Germany and one of the
particular guys that I'm working with at
the moment he was asking about how to be
a better conversation list
he's quite forthcoming he's got a lot a
lot to say and he's clever and he's
quick but he knows that he grates on
people he knows that he can come across
a little bit abrasive and he asked me
for some sort of heuristic or rule to
use and I was like I want you to ask one
question for every statement that you
make when you have a conversation with
one of the guys in your office that's
known and even you can put what you want
them to do into your question so you can
say okay what do you think is a solution
to this or how would you go about doing
this or can you tell me why you think
that you know and if you realize that it
not only does it help you to understand
their point of view and if you can
ensure that you're letting go of your
ego and that you haven't got your battle
mode on and you're not pulling too hard
and do the things that we've discussed
beforehand and you're you're prepared to
be sort of moved by the tide of the
conversation you can less sway from left
to right however it goes you again you
two plus two equals five in that
conversation absolutely yeah it's it's a
skill and again I don't think people
have been intentionally practicing this
or being taught the skill but the actual
skill is not you don't have to go and
get your PhD and asking questions you
can actually just put you know write
down five questions put it in your
pocket and next time you go out you know
and talk to someone just like review it
really quickly before you go in and be
like okay I'm going to ask those
questions and then asking them see where
it goes and it's self reinforcing
because once you started doing that you
realize how enjoyable it is to hear
people talk about something that you
weren't expecting them to talk about and
to hear someone's own words sistah to
describe something and so I like this
one because it is like one of the first
most like obvious reinforcing loops
where you get an instant gratification
from a session you really do a thing
certainly before doing this pocket
summon I'm an only child and that meant
that I had a very very single-minded
solitary selfish worldview which I
probably still do and my friends but
it's a lot better since doing the
podcast because I have a genuine
curiosity of what other people say and I
can't I can no longer turn that off so
someone will get kicked out at the front
of one of our club nights and I'll be
stood on the door and this person will
be shouting and screaming about why the
door stuff had kicked them out and I'll
be asking them like tell me about what
you do for work interested in your
backstory please yeah right there Oh God
standing on the front door honestly if I
had one of those body cams on that the
police were it would be it'd be cyber
dread Halloween last night in New Castle
and there's nothing better than seeing a
guy dressed up as a Ghostbuster fight a
guy dressed up as a Power Ranger in the
doorstep try to split them up and me
being like excuse me jump someone can
you tell me about where the moral virtue
that's starting this situation versus I
mean how are they gonna resolve anything
different you know that's really correct
but yeah the asking questions thing
super easy heuristic moving on number
six well we got okay so number six is
building arguments together so once so
this is another thing that I like to
practice and then you know I think it's
you have to get good two questions first
but building AI Rancic together is
basically like let's just put aside my
position for a while and let's really
work on making your argument or your
side of the position and as strong as
possible and I can help you by both
seeing pricing from the outside as well
and you can help from seeing it from the
inside you can look for the answers to
my questions together we can look for I
can look at the evidence that you have
as sort of you help you explain it in
language that I could hear better all
these things where you're now rather
than trying to tear apart their argument
you're trying to build it up because in
an ideal world a disagreement would be
something that you can learn from and
you can only learn from the best version
of the argument you so that means you
need to find the people that can best
represent the argument and help them
make it stronger
and you know this is a collaborative
exercise and you could just do this with
almost anything there's a best argument
for even the most wrong positions and we
can make a best argument for Flat Earth
you can make the best argument for you
know the world being on top of the stack
of Turtles I mean about you and by doing
that you like suddenly you're back into
your creative mode you're back into your
like okay well let's make this work and
you're doing it with somebody that has a
lot to contribute because our enemies
and our opponents actually are the best
at spotting our own blind spots and
we're the best of spotting theirs and if
we're actually working together there's
a huge amount of benefit from using that
knowledge of each other to make each
other stronger ultimately you might
build up the argument brag okay well I
still don't believe the earth is flat
but you know I had a lot of fun doing
that you know and maybe they during the
process they might be like okay well I
and I had an experience where I talked
to a globalist and they you know they
didn't try to hurt me or tell me I'm an
idiot I open the door to them asking you
questions about your argument or like
how you got to your side because that
you know I gave you you know some of my
time they might eventually want to give
it back yeah I'm thinking of two
examples here which you might be
familiar with both I think it is Charlie
Munger who says that he refuses to have
a position on anything unless he can
state the other side better than they
can right yeah exactly
that's an amazing heuristic and then you
might have seen the Pangburn philosophy
discussion between Jordan Pederson and
Sam Harris and they started they they
did it they did what's called steel
money it's all right
yes honey can you explain what steel
money in argument is still meaning is
it's a version of this which is like I'm
gonna try to articulate the you know the
best case of this argument
it doesn't necessarily require the other
person to be involved which i think is a
crucial part of it because they actually
have a lot more of the information than
you do but yeah it's basically saying
hey if I don't think that that's moral
to you know not vaccinate your kids I
could create the steel man argument of
that of the other person's side by
trying to
use evidence in its beautifully you know
notion is pop so well said I imagine
someone like this and this and this and
in that case you know I can see why you
know they don't have time to go give
their kids vaccinations and that's why
they don't do it or they live in Nigeria
there's no access to clinics you know
whatever it happens to be but taking
everything on as good of faith as
possible sometimes it's also called the
principle of charity of just you know
helping them I think the crucial thing
that they all sort of triangulate on is
that we're usually in the mode of trying
to hear people's arguments down and that
makes us not see the strengths versus
when you steal man you can sort of do
the opposite you look for the strengths
and you look to make them stronger and
you look to you know try to imagine
because that's when we're arguing on
behalf of ourselves that's what we're
doing we're imagining it in this best
light we're not in mentioning its flaws
so it helps you with that method Dean
okay yeah yeah I agree and again to come
back to the the asking questions part a
lot of the guys that work for us you can
imagine there's a million micro
decisions that need to get made about
club nights who's working this week what
are the hostess outfits should we do
confetti or should we do bubbles or
should we do whatever and everyone's
different point of view and a lot of the
time I've noticed that the guys that
work there may be 1819 up to 21 22 and a
lot of the guys like to make statements
about things as as fact but then they're
never actually prepared to look at what
the other side is saying and understand
that and then another thing I wonder
whether you've come across this probably
will have done people are a lot more
prepared in a disagreement to say why
another thing is wrong than to offer a
solution mm-hmm right yeah I mean this
is always the case out I call this like
arguing at the gate so we recommend take
any issue
we're often just trying to point out the
flaws of the other side we're not
talking about what are what we would do
if we were allowed to good deal with the
thing that we're trying to do right like
there's an example today of like you
know with the Facebook ad policy I don't
know if you follow that or not but
they're trying to say like you know
Facebook should ban
ads that are blatantly lying about stuff
and you know that there's a good case
for it and you know there's a lot of you
know heat around this right now but no
one's talking about what that policy
should be like what it how would we
censor political ads in a productive way
there are plenty of countries that do
and some of them are tyrannical
countries so we don't we know that
that's not just enough to censor ads but
we also have to create a good policy and
that's so you don't you can leave the
games like say imagine that we resolve
this disagreement somehow what would we
do with that victory we how would we
actually be how would we execute on the
on the answer and it's it's surprising
how little we actually think about that
I think that's that's certainly
something I see arguing at the gate is
that what you called it yeah yeah yeah
then arguing at the gate it's that's
just all the Twitter is to me I don't
know whether it's a result of the
character limit that a lot of the time
you are restricted to just put in like
this is my point this is the
hardest-hitting bit of it which is
usually a criticism of your point but
yeah we default we default to that don't
wait because recently Twitter said that
they're banning all political ads is
this is this a second-order effect this
Facebook pressure a second-order effect
you think of the Twitter thing I think
they're both sort of swirling in that
same same discussion Facebook it's more
so because they're much bigger but yeah
Twitter and I you know LinkedIn and
Pinterest also recently came out saying
that you know even before Twitter that
they are gonna not have any political
ads and it's applauded by a lot of the
critics of Facebook and but it also
opens up a whole nother question of like
okay well how will you draw the line
when you define a political idea Donald
Trump's undergone a body transformation
and he wants to sell you is like six
week Beachbody program or something yeah
so like now we're moving the we're
moving into another gate you know we're
now after like what counts as an issue a
political issue and can I advertise
about it and it's gonna be just as
heated that's a little bit more nuanced
which i think is good but it's still
gonna be a hard one I think
this the fact that people are so
prepared and you know I am as well I you
know there's inflammatory stuff that I
see online and I get a visceral reaction
and I want to reply or say the e stupid
or whatever but a lot of things it's
everything is so complex
everything's so so difficult the real
world's incredibly messy incredibly
chaotic and it's increasingly we're just
not having very good conversations about
things it doesn't it doesn't really seem
on the whole to be getting that much
better I'm aware that I live in this
wonderful podcast utopia where it's just
me and some person that I've had a bit
of a chat with over email chatting about
something that fascinates us both the
vast majority people it's not that
especially for the guys at the top of
the tree you know like if you'd someone
whose real real that typical normal
mainstream media you got your 30 second
snippet sat on a panel with like five
other people who all disagree with you
yeah yeah it's hard I mean we weren't
ever in this situation before where we
had a giant audience and no context for
who we are what we what group were in
all kind of things so I think it's
really it's sort of you know the we're
in this learning phase of a new
technology a new environment and we're
making all kinds of mistakes we don't
have the skills but it is an opportunity
to step back and and first you know have
a bit of sympathy for everyone that's
sort of flailing and failing in this
context because none of us are good at
it and give people a chance to develop
as people and to learn from mistakes and
to learn from each other and I think you
know having one-on-one conversations is
a lot easier than having one to a
million person conversations and so we
can build that skill up from smaller
smaller circles and smaller situations
and build our confidence and create new
cultural norms about how to disagree I
think that's just part of the process
we're gonna go through as a culture it's
like let's learn these skills starting
from the very basics and I you know
we're still very early in our and our
evolution on terms of like how do we
exist on online as humans very much so
have you have you seen those political
debates I don't want to have them in the
States and other of them in the UK where
the audience members have a button that
tells them that shows at the bottom of
the screen I think it's called the worm
so you can imagine there's lines for
each of the candidates moving across the
screen like that and then they go up and
down and say different things and you
can track and it's all Reds red said
something really bad or blues made red
silly so red looks worse and blah blah
have you seen those things I have yeah
they do it for debates yeah
and I've seen them also done in like a
town hall can a situation okay like
there's a there's a there's a
methodology around it I don't think it's
great because it turns it turns
conversation into a sport right it turns
it into who could score points you can
like get the zingers you can no sort of
make the other person look like a fool
it's definitely not about coming to an
agreement or seeing things eye-to-eye
very twice Ariel isn't it doing it that
way yeah yeah yeah I mean I think the
intentions are good and there's a bunch
of no and you know perhaps in a court of
law or you know when you talk about
policy and very specific problem spaces
it would work but I think at a national
level political debates that's not good
and it turns it into a football game
yeah I think again another Sam Harris
ism I think he was talking about when he
either does debates or just generally
panel shows so this could be either
adversarial or collaborative and he was
saying that a lot of the time the person
who comes out feeling like they were the
best wasn't the person who was the most
lucid or the person who articulated
their argument the best or whatever it
was it's if you get one huge raucous
laugh from the crowd like if you've got
the biggest laugh you want right which
is bizarre because you know some some
could be talking about some real
contentious serious topics like the the
reality of Islam in the West or the the
laws surrounding abortion or the concept
of consciousness or whatever it is and
then someone makes a funny joke and it's
like oh he won you know I know I mean
that because if you're there
to be entertained so that's that's what
you're there for then the laughs will
definitely give you the points and I
call them zingers where there's a whole
science I think two zingers where you
know you're not actually talking to that
person you're just trying to make them
look foolish you're mostly talking to
your own side about like you know how
could I be the best sort of soldier or
the best you know flag bearer of my side
and like say things in such a way that
just you know create bewilderment or
confusion in the other side or top dome
or you know all these things where it's
very social but tied back to work
behavior again you know the goal is
definitely not to get along yeah it's a
Android oil and can stunt in kissing her
two comedians political comedians in the
UK I've spoken to them both recently saw
them at the Edinburgh Fringe and both of
them said the same thing about I think
they call it applauded comedy which is
where the comedian doesn't necessarily
say something funny they just say the
thing that the audience agrees with the
most and then they wasn't even funny it
wasn't it wasn't funny you just said
something that you think might but you
can't say that anymore like that's a
classic one you know like and it just Oh
anyone who's thinks that free speech is
being attacked is like yeah yeah of
course yeah or he was like who here is
from New York you know to be anything
that's loyalty based it I like it you
know what is it what is it how can my
tribe be be heard right now and I will
get the applause right so polls poll
bloomed the other day when I was talking
to him and you may have heard of this
particular experiment so you said that
you put people into a room and you get
them all to flip a coin so 100 people in
the room getting flipping coin roughly
50 a heads 50 or tails or whatever it
might be and then you put them on
opposite sides of the room and you got
the tails people you know what do you
what do you think of heads and there you
have been selected by the most arbitrary
random chance
literally the most arbitrary random
chance that you can get and we're still
drawn towards being tribal yeah yeah
there's something emotionally rewarding
about being part of a trend
we want to belong and the way that we
vote we build status within a tribe is
by you know being a good member of it
which means like sort of protecting the
tribe projecting confidence all these
sort of safety
increasing traits that signal that our
tribe is going to be ok even if we were
on two sides of a cliff in the winter
and like no who knows why the bridge
broke but would you know we were on two
different sides we want art we want our
side to survive the winter and you know
it's it's it makes sense if you just
think about you know how many you know
generations of our society have
benefited from these preferences it's
you know if we ended up preferring like
it was like well the other side probably
have blankets let's go give them our
blankets you know your your tribes not
gonna survive to everybody yeah I
suppose as well this probably highlights
where the difficulty with subtlety and
nuance comes in as well because if
you're part of X tribe they want you to
swallow the ideology wholesale and any
give that you might not be singing from
the same hymn sheet is actually oh well
maybe maybe busted maybe did maybe
doesn't belong even on our side yeah
yeah maybe he's on the other side and
that's why again Paul was talking about
for instance someone who's very very
left-leaning but has country views to do
with abortion law or someone who's very
very free speech but thinks that the in
that needs to be policed more heavily or
whatever it might be and you know that
again it's hard for everyone to try and
work out what their views are and we
need productive disagreement for you to
help me understand what I think and for
me to help you understand what you think
so right we've done two two chapters
left we go seven and eight yes we do yes
I wanna say one more thing about that
though exactly there is there is so much
to say about this tribal stuff it's
really the underpinning of all of our
thoughts around disagreement which is
like if you even just look back at birds
you know birds can't will kick members
out of their flock if they're caught
stealing
you know if there are times when there's
scarcity and one bird is eating all the
food and never going out hunting that
bird will be you know exile are oft
sized from their tribe and so this sense
of like you know learn to stay in the
group you have to contribute and the
worst punishment of any group is to be
removed from the group like that's how
we enforce all of our laws is like if
you don't follow the rules we kick you
out and that works as long as you know
in the past you know you kick someone
out and they probably end up dying right
because there's no other group that's
gonna take them in now we keep people
out and they're like oh hey you know
troublemaker come over to our trouble
tribe we're gonna help you become
stronger and we have all these other
weapons we can you know and we're
building this new no argument that's
gonna go attack them next next year you
know in ten years and so the things that
worked in our tribes the past of like
you know follow the rules or else now in
a world where everyone can find a
community no matter how sort of Fringe
you are and those fringe groups can
become stronger and more angry at you
like the the feedback loop is now where
you kick out it's gonna come back you
know ten times stronger I'm the future
so it's just interesting dynamic that
requires different instincts for asked
to manage so anyway the last two are
sort of relevant so one of them the
second to last one is to cultivate
neutral spaces so spaces you know start
speaking of tribes where you don't have
to always signal loyalty to the group
you don't always have to repeat the
ideas of the authority figure you don't
always have to even like you know be
productive in that group but like so
imagine a dinner table or you know
something where I can anyone can bring
an idea to the table it could be a bad
idea it can be a good idea those kinds
of that makes it neutral on terms of
ideas we're no one has to endorse the
idea just but in order to talk about it
you can talk about it you know and be
critical of it but it's welcome to the
table the second level of that is like
who's a lot in the room you know can can
anyone arrive into the room and present
their ideas can we allow no terrorists
and Trump supporters into the room to
tell us like what's wrong what's going
on with them the danger that we fear is
that like if we didn't fight them to the
room they're gonna come in and
attack us and you know we'll give them
validation and all the stuff that you
know that they came to do in bad faith
but and truly neutral space would allow
ideas to flow in and out good and bad
ones and it allow people to flow in and
out and good and bad ones over time and
some places can cultivate this and
others it becomes obvious that's not
gonna ever happen you know when other
interests like you know revenue or you
know costs are involved you have to make
choices about who can be there and who
can't and slowly over time that create
systemic problems where people are
undervalued and unhappy and marginalized
and you know whether it be you know the
poorest people in the country are the
most disenfranchised people in the
country or it be the people that were
previously you know in the ruling class
but are now being neglected you know
everyone can feel outcast in that sense
and unwelcome to the main group you know
however there's all this talk about the
elites sort of like criticizing the
common people the comment people are
feeling displaced and they're not they
don't feel like it's a neutral space so
I think there's ways for us to work on
that now the last one is sort of a meta
point to sort of try to wrap up the
whole thing which is to rather than
reject reality and reject that the world
is like this just like accept that you
know we have our problems
no one's know is perfect we all have a
you know a thread of between good and
evil that goes between us
none of us to be perfectly one or the
other and we have to get into the fray
regardless with people that are
imperfect because we too are imperfect
we don't need to use purity tests to
like test loyalty but rather get it-get
sort of working on the problems and
start you know getting making progress
on that stuff instead of trying to just
make sure that the whole world is
perfect before you agree to go touch it
you don't have to wait for politics to
be completely revamped to become a
politician you don't have to wait for
you know the tech industry to be
completely revamp you don't have to wait
for any industry to be fixed before you
go in and try to help make it better
yeah so the the first point that you've
talked about there I suppose with
canceled culture and blockades around
particular rallies or speeches where
they one of my ex podcast guests and her
friends Alex who's at the University of
Oxford
Steve Bannon was going to go and talk
and some students should just block the
street they're like no no you can't go
you can't go listen to him we're not
going to let anyone through - listen -
right well I mean if his ideas are that
bad you should be able to say at the Q&A
at the end
just zinger the hell out of him make him
look a fool but it's easier it's easier
to just try and shut down the argument
entirely but bizarrely it always it
almost always seems to work against
people you know ben shapiro needs like
14 security guards with him whenever he
goes to go speak on campus and all this
sort of stuff and then yeah that with
the with your final point there that the
fact that you need to accept the world
as it is I'm finding that mechanism
appear in so many different areas of
life at the moment and there's a good
piece of advice for anyone who's
listening if you are continuing to come
up against the same problem you know
that the world shouldn't be that way but
it continues to manifest its like sorry
but the world isn't changing as fast as
you wanted to and you just you just need
to account for that so we say all the
time with the with the managers or with
some of the stuff that work for us or
whatever it might be we wish that they
would be sufficiently autonomous with X
tasks that we don't need to remind them
but after three weeks of them not doing
it when we don't tell them despite the
fact that we scheduled for them to do it
yep
that this is just a thing where the
world is the way it is and I'm gonna
have to send them a message on the
morning that reminds them to do the X
task or the Y task or whatever it might
be and that that appears to be rolling
forward for everything because we want
the world to just happen right we want
it to be this autonomous beast where we
do the work once and it just scales
beautifully is this like evergreen you
top here right
we always expectations we don't want it
you know we have an expectation and when
it doesn't line up that
makes us a little bit anxious and so we
can either decide like okay well there's
something broken over there I'm gonna
stay away from it you should fix
yourself or we're gonna help develop
that and help them improve and get
involved ourselves but yeah it is a hard
instinct to overcome it's very tempting
to want to just hide the problems over
there and say hey you got a probably go
fix it versus being the part of them of
the solution
I suppose that manifests is one of the
as the third option that you spoke about
earlier on which is just eggs at the
conversation thing as well right it's
like I'll look like this is this is just
pointless I know you mean a bother not
even gonna bother engaging yeah well I
mean if there's one surefire way of
making certain that the world's not
going to change its doing that exactly
so to wrap up if you were to give the
people that are listening your one
favorite single heuristic or rule or
piece of advice when it comes to having
a productive disagreement what would it
be well I mean I think that the overall
desire that I would sort of want to
plant in people's heads is that we can
get better at this like we can become
you know 1% 5% 10% better at disagreeing
productively and the only way we can do
that is by practicing so find the
arguments out there that in the
disagreements that you're avoiding
currently and one that's within like the
skill level not too hard not too easy
you know especially at first if you
don't know where you are on that scale
practice it and intentionally try to get
better than this is a this is like going
to the gym right this is how we get
along with each other
is a skill we need to develop in
ourselves because once we develop it in
ourselves we can feel it in ourselves we
can sort of remember what it's like we
can expect others to also have that and
I think that's one of the only ways we
can enact change in the world is to
expect our leaders to be better expect
our you know the people above us to to
be better but we can only expect that of
them once
we know what it is ourselves and so you
know I think we can start there
to begin and you know once once you get
hooked on it I think you'll you'll find
every conversation to be like a little
adventure that you know it's it's gonna
you don't know where it's saying go it's
gonna be it's gonna be unpredictable
because you're no longer just guard
railing it or trying to shut it down and
it leads to really interesting things
it's highly rewarding so I just you know
I hope people turn this into a practice
it's that's my goal I like it I think
we've we've used a really lovely
framework today it's certainly something
I think will challenge a lot of people
they've got a lot of biases to overcome
visceral responses to things emotion the
ego all the the the things that manifest
themselves verbal and pop inside of our
brains but yeah you know like I say go
go and have a conversation have a long
conversation with people have a think
about what we spoking one of the odd
casts honestly what the stupid thing now
is that you can do an IG live a dual IG
live with someone else I'm actually
gonna start doing this for the podcast
I'm gonna do just a weekly 15-minute
chat with someone else
it's not not as structured not published
on any other platforms well just exist
but you can anyone can do that anyone
got some form of social media and okay
well so what was it the Christian Buster
said oh I need the I need the external
accountability of someone else that's
going that's gonna be listening to hold
me to like high level of rigor and blah
blah there you go you know just press
press a button press your live button
and get one of your friends to join you
you know that that might that might
nourish the the particular only thing so
why are we yelling the art of productive
disagreement will be linked in the show
notes below and it's at Buster on
Twitter I mean that's the advantage of
being one of the first guys in Twitter
isn't it when you get to get a blister
yep yep yep I had a tits them to you but
then I accidentally canceled discount no
way you watch our Instagram yeah yeah
you know sloppy you could have helped
you could have held them to search
around or just used it to shamelessly
promote your own book exactly yes
I love it if there are any other places
are you mostly on Twitter is that what's
best to find that's Witter I you have a
blog of Buster Benson calm I'm on medium
and Buster as well so but Twitter is
really the best place to start and I'm
open
you know at mentions will will get
replies so and just like the time to
people fantastic well as I've said
everything that we've spoken about will
be in the show notes below
of course why we yelling the art of
productive disagreement is linked and as
always if you follow that link you'll be
supporting this podcast at no extra
expense to yourself if you enjoyed this
episode go follow Buster online haslums
got a great handle on on twitter like
share subscribe you know all of that
good stuff but for now thanks very much
Buster it's been awesome man it's been
great thank you so much
[Music]
you